you're not built for this these boys
come in here they gotta fight for life
people died in the ring your daddy died
in the ring I'll know him Hank I nothing
do with me let me fight in my whole life
it's not a choice for me berry punch
ever Thrones been I'm all you might show
me how to do this right no specialist at
least it's it dies
wives in the flyer below leather leather
Medicare beyond
dirty needles make another record
the goat says that little rose in the
way
let's pitch he from the 10th round on
the first fight right I heard about a
third fight between you and Apollo
behind closed doors that's rude
how do you know all this I'm a son
looking at the world through the TV a
table rapping over
in the late night
a great fighter once said it ain't about
how hard you can hit
it's about how hard you can get you
and keep moving forward she just got
here that's the toughest opponent you're
ever gonna have to face I believe that's
true Lorraine and I think that's true
life to show me something annotated
Obama cans outside a violation fish